de vous accueillir ici dans le cadre de
cette commission d'enquête sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques en
matière de rénovation énergétique nous
achevons quasiment nos auditions avec
vous-même votre collègue Christophe
Béchu qui va nous suivre et Olivier
Klein que nous auditionnerons la semaine
prochaine nous achevons donc nos
auditions avec les trois ministres
actuellement en exercice en
responsabilité de ces questions là
sachant qu'on a commencé nos auditions
de la commission d'enquête à la fin du
mois de janvier au mois de février avec
l'ensemble des ministres depuis 2012 qui
ont eu dans leur responsabilité soit la
transition écologique énergétique et où
le logement donc merci à vous madame la
ministre vous occupez cette fonction
depuis le 20 mai 2022 auparavant vous
avez été secrétaire d'État auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
d'octobre 2018 à juillet 2020 puis
ministre délégué chargé de l'industrie
de juillet 2020 jusqu'à mai 2022 la
rénovation des logements est au cœur de
la politique de la transition
énergétique de la France je souhaite
donc en préambule que vous puissiez nous
exposer la stratégie de la France en la
matière quelle est la place de la
rénovation énergétique des logements
dans la transition énergétique d'ici à
2030 entre 2030 et 2050 et au-delà
comment contribue-t-elle à relever le
défi du mur énergétique qui attend la
France en 2030 selon l'expression que
vous avez vous-même employé nous
aimerions également vous entendre sur ce
que vous considérez comme les principaux
freins à la politique de rénovation
énergétique des logements en France et
les améliorations possibles
dans le cadre de la Stratégie nationale
bas carbone le pays s'est donné
l'objectif de disposer d'un parc
entièrement rénové aux normes Bâtiment
Basse Consommation BBC en 2050 ce qui
supposeraient la rénovation performante
d'au moins 500 000 logements par an
pourtant hier la première ministre on a
annoncé que 200 000 rénovations
performantes à l'horizon 2024 à
l'occasion de la conclusion du Conseil
national de la refondation sur le
logement en parallèle la teinte de
l'objectif de réduction de 55% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
2030 par rapport à 1990 suppose d'après
le secrétariat général à la
planification écologique que nous avons
également auditionné un effort de
réduction de 27 millions de tonnes de
c12e
CO2 par la rénovation énergétique des
logements dont 17 millions de tonnes de
CO2 qui seraient évitée grâce au
remplacement des chaudières à cet égard
lors du Conseil national de la
transition écologique du 22 mai
président madame la Première ministre il
a été évoqué l'interdiction des
chaudières à gaz dans la lignée de celle
des chaudières à fioul pouvez-vous nous
donner un certain nombre de précisions
sur cette mesure est-ce que l'accent mit
sur le remplacement des systèmes de
chauffage pourraient se faire au
détriment du renforcement de l'isolation
des bâtiments et donc de l'atteinte des
objectifs de la Stratégie nationale bas
carbone de plus est-ce que cela ne
conduirait pas à donner à l'électricité
une place trop importante et peut-être
non soutenable dans le mix énergétique
du pays
dans le cadre d'une audition à
l'Assemblée nationale le 31 mai dernier
vous avez annoncé vouloir travailler sur
la question du reste à charge zéro pour
les ménages modestes le reste à charge
en effet de l'un des principaux
obstacles de la politique de rénovation
énergétique pour ce ménage mais dans le
même temps atteindre un reste à charge 0
comporte des effets pervers notamment
pour des raisons de fraude comme on peut
le montrer des offres à 1 euro plusieurs
acteurs accompagnant les ménages très
modestes nous ont également fait part de
leur réserves pour des raisons de
dignité ces personnes souhaitant être
partie prenante de la rénovation de leur
logement comment donc diminuer le reste
à charge des ménages tout en maintenant
un signal prix suffisant et s'assurer de
l'engagement des personnes directement
concernées
à ce titre les prêts à la rénovation
énergétique que ce soit l'éco PTZ ou le
prêt avance rénovation le part sont des
outils essentiels pour financer le reste
à charge des ménages mais ils n'ont pas
encore atteint les ménages modestes le
préavancent rénovation en particulier
est cibler sur les ménages modestes mais
il est très peu distribué comment
expliquer vous ce faible déploiement le
gouvernement a-t-il des propositions
concrètes pour l'améliorer puisque le
point a été évoqué hier soir par madame
la Première ministre
avant de vous laisser la parole madame
la ministre pour répondre à ses
premières questions il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc vous en avez l'habitude dans le
cadre de commission d'enquête madame la
ministre a prêté serment de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité a levé la
main droite et à dire je le jure
je le jure je vous remercie je vous
laisse donc la parole et ensuite votre
rapporteur et nos collègues ne
manqueront pas de vous poser un certain
nombre de questions complémentaires je
vous remercie merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de
modifier dans le cadre de vos travaux
consacrés à la rénovation énergétique et
vous savez que ces travaux seront
également pris en compte donc m'attendre
le rapport dans le cadre des travaux que
nous menons pour la loi de programmation
énergique climat et les cadres et les
sept groupes de travail qui ont été
lancés en début de en début de mois
avant de venir aux différents axes
d'action de la politique que je porte
peut-être un mot général sur le sujet
clairement parmi tous les leviers de la
transition énergétique sur lequel
agilement ministère sauver levier là à
une sensibilité particulière
pour nous concitoyens et en particulier
les plus jeunes alors évidemment on peut
penser aux différentes manifestations de
citoyens ou associatif mais j'entends
également une attente forte sur cette
question d'abord en raison d'une prise
de conscience collective du poids
considérable du secteur du bâtiment dans
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
le rappelle 18 pouces dans lequel chacun
à titre individuel et c'est probablement
la deuxième raison peut agir puisque
nous sommes tous a priori sauf un nombre
réduit de personnes logées quelque part
et donc il y a ce cette deuxième raison
c'est la capacité à agir à son échelle
contre le dérèglement climatique et puis
troisième raison qui ressort d'ailleurs
de vos travaux ce souci de justice
sociale car ces travaux ce ne sont pas
seulement des contraintes mais aussi des
opportunités pour les logements
d'aller vers plus de confort je pense
que ce point-là est essentiel et qu'il
mérite d'être valorisé peut-être plus
fortement grâce à une plus grande
chaleur conservée l'hiver grâce à une
plus grande fraîcheur pendant l'été on
se rend peut-être pas encore compte mais
c'est un sujet qui devrait monter dans
les années qui viennent
et puis c'est évidemment plus de pouvoir
d'achat de manière pérenne car les
factures d'énergie se stabilisent et
baisse par rapport à les références
avec sans rénovation or et vous l'avez
très bien dit chacun n'a pas les moyens
de se payer ses travaux je ne centrerai
pas mon propos sur
les autres bâtiments que sont les
tertiaires républiques je veux juste
dire quand même que dans la question de
des trajectoires carbone du bâtiment il
est très important de les considérer et
d'avoir aussi c'est peut-être un peu
plus simple compte tenu des
propriétaires qui sont équipés en
ingénierie etc quoi que il faut aussi
avoir une politique très claire parce
que
ce sont des travaux qui doivent être
menés avec des perspectives des budgets
et des jalons et des financements
publics et privés s'agissant du
résidentiel il représente plus de 30% de
notre consommation en énergie 10% nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
rénovation thermique du parc de logement
est une priorité de l'agenda climatique
nationale présentée par la première
ministre le 22 mai dernier vous y avez
fait mention cet agenda s'inscrit plus
globalement dans les objectifs très
ambitieux fixés par le Président de la
République de faire de la France le
premier grand pays au monde à sortir de
sa dépendance aux énergies fossiles pour
atteindre une neutralité carbone en 2050
la rénovation énergétique et c'est assez
d'écart un des grands leviers de notre
stratégie énergétique qui se décline en
cas de piliers efficacité énergétique
évidemment dont la rénovation est une
composante essentielle sobriété
énergétique déploiement des énergies
renouvelables et relance historique de
la filière nucléaire permettez-moi juste
de rappeler que l'année 2022 a vu la
baisse de nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de
2,7%. je pense que c'est important de se
le dire parce que compte tenu de la
crise énergétique dans lequel nous
étions n'étaient pas du tout une
performance si aisée à atteindre que la
sobriété a permis de le faire et je veux
donner un chiffre parce qu'il est
intéressant avec les rang par rapport à
vos travaux les bâtiments ont baissé
leurs émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sur toute l'année de 15%. donc on voit
bien en tout cas c'est une première
recommandation qu'il ne faut pas séparer
efficacité énergétique et sobriété
énergétique c'est une façon aussi
d'aborder l'effet rebonds qui revient
souvent dans les problématiques sur les
politiques d'efficacité de rénovation
thermique
une fois ces choses dites permettez-moi
d'en venir à la politique que nous
menons depuis le Grenelle de
l'environnement initié par Jean-Louis
Borloo la France s'est fixée pour des
objectifs ambitieux de rénovation
énergétique et pour y parvenir l'état
déployé de nombreux dispositifs pour
inciter les Français à rénover leur
logement je vais évidemment rappeler le
crédit d'impôt de transition énergétique
qui a été supprimé en 2020 et qui marque
un changement de philosophie majeur sous
le précédent quinquennat avec la
création de ma prime rénove pourquoi
nous l'avons fait d'abord parce que
l'aide était finalement mal ciblée
puisqu'elle bénéficier à peu de ménage
et de plus plutôt ménage les plus aisés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
pris la décision de repenser de
réorienter le dispositif vers les
ménages les plus modestes
ensuite nous l'avons fait car le
dispositif financier essentiellement du
monogest avec des gains énergétiques et
climatiques modestes je pense notamment
classique changement de fenêtre le
quinquennat précédent a permis des
avancées structurantes pour répondre à
ces différents acteurs écueil ma prime
rénove qui a été lancée en 2020 a permis
de massifier des éco-gestes chez les
ménages avec plus d'un,6 millions de
projets de travaux engagés et des de
depuis 2020 elle est plus juste
puisqu'elle a réorienté les financements
à plus de 80% en faveur des ménages
modestes alors comment les définit-on
dire que ce sont les quatre premiers des
cils donc 40% de la population contre
10% seulement avec l'ancien crédit
d'impôt
sur le suivi qualitatif des opérations
la refonte du diagnostic de performance
énergétique nous dotent d'un outil plus
solide pour évaluer réellement la
performance environnementale du parc
c'est un indicateur fondamental pour
appliquer le calendrier ambitieux de la
loi climat résilience des radications
des passoires thermiques dans le parc
locatif nous avons aussi renforcé
l'accompagnement grâce au lancement en
début d'année 2022 c'est finalement
assez récent du service public de la
rénovation de l'habitat France Renov
cette marque unique qui rassemble le
réseau de l'ADEME et de l'ANAH doit nous
permettre d'offrir partout sur le
territoire un point d'entrée délivrant
une information et un conseil de qualité
sur les travaux et les aides
mobilisables
l'évolution majeure du crédit d'impôt
vers ma prime rénov a eu aussi des
résultats sur l'efficacité énergétique
des opérations puisque le dispositif a
permis en 2021 l'augmentation des
économies d'énergie annuelle de l'ordre
de 40% par rapport au crédit d'impôt en
2019 l'impact carbone du dispositif et
parieur très positif puisque 90% des
systèmes de chauffage renouvelables
installés se substitue au fioul ou au
gaz nous nous y retrouvons donc au
regard de notre objectif de
décarbonation des logements c'est là que
se pose d'ailleurs une question c'est
que
poursuivre deux objectifs un objectif de
baisse de réduction de notre
consommation d'énergie un objectif de
réduction de nos gaz et effet de serre
et pour des raisons d'efficacité ces
deux objectifs ne sont pas totalement
convergents et donc il y a avoir ces
aspects en tête lorsqu'on choisit nos
politiques publiques
évidemment nous pouvons aller plus loin
je pense que le constat il est assez
partagé ici maintenant que nous avons
posé les bases pour la structuration
d'un service public unifié de l'habitat
nous voulons renforcer l'efficacité de
cette politique accélérer la réduction
de la consommation d'énergie et la
sortie des passoires thermiques je
rappelle d'ailleurs que il y a un texte
qui va nous y inviter très directement
qui est la directive sur la performance
énergétique des bâtiments qui est assez
dimensionnant aujourd'hui il est en
discussion à peu près en ce moment
au niveau en trilogue mais il a une
vision qui est assez alignée qui est
même légèrement moins 10 ans à la loi
française vous savez que nous nous
plaidons pour une réévaluation et en
fait un alignement sur la loi française
mais ça veut dire que nous sommes en
train de créer au-delà de la France une
véritable de véritable filière au niveau
européen pour accompagner cette mutation
c'est pas indifférent pour les
politiques que nous menons
notre marche à franchir les très hautes
vous les avez vous l'avez rappelé les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
secteur du bâtiment sont de 75 millions
de tonnes en 2021 il faudrait atteindre
30 millions de tonnes en 2030 soit une
baisse de plus de 60%. et c'est cette
trajectoire là aujourd'hui qui est
grosso modo discuté dans les
trajectoires SNBC sur lequel nous avons
nous menons les concertations avec des
sénateurs des députés et des élus locaux
et les filières
avec mes collègues Christophe BECHU et
Olivier Klein nous avons identifié
plusieurs axes de travail d'abord
fiabiliser le parcours usagé en portant
une attention particulière aux délais de
traitement des dossiers même si les
retards concernent moins de 2% des 700
000 dossiers traités par an ce sont
quand même des milliers de dossiers en
trop et c'est surtout un espèce de bruit
de fond négatifs qui vont polluer et qui
peuvent retarder le passage à l'acte des
ménages français une attention
particulière aussi aux
dysfonctionnements de la plateforme tout
en étant absolument intraitable sur les
fraudes et les tentatives de fraude j'y
reviendrai il faut néanmoins avoir
conscience de ce point de tension on ne
peut pas en même temps vouloir des
contrôles toujours plus rapides et
pointer l'existence d'arnaques et de
fautes donc il y a un juste milieu à
définir et on sent bien qu'on est en
train de
tester des équilibres depuis quelques
mois
ensuite je souhaite que nous accélions
le remplacement des 11 millions de
chaudières gaz et des plus de 2,7
millions de chaudières fuel la
concertation que nous avons lancée hier
doit permettre de documenter avec les
acteurs de la filière les solutions
alternatives
en considération des enjeux
environnementaux mais aussi évidemment
économique géographique parce qu'on n'a
pas les mêmes solutions suivants qu'on
est sur un territoire rural suivant
qu'on est au nord de la France aussi on
est au sud de la France et sociaux je
veux dire à ce point que l'alternative à
une chaudière fioul ou une chaudière gaz
n'est pas nécessairement l'électricité
on sait tous que la chaleur renouvelable
est un levier qui est particulièrement
puissant avec un coût d'abattement de la
tonne carbone qui est compétitif qu'il y
a aussi la possibilité de passer par la
géothermie on y reviendra peut-être ce
n'est pas un gigantesque gisement comme
on peut lire ici les c'est quand même
une énergie tout à fait intéressante et
surtout permanente
et que donc il ne faut pas se limiter au
seul aux seuls enjeux de l'électricité
deuxièmement par rapport à cette
à cette perspective
l'objectif c'est d'anticiper plutôt en
anticipe plus on a de temps d'organiser
du côté de l'offre les filières
industrielles les filières de service
pour permettre ces changements pour les
ménages et du côté des ménages la prise
de conscience le changement évidemment
au moment où la chaudière casse
ça si on peut éviter de remplacer
du fossile par du fossile ça paraît
assez naturel si c'est une solution
effective sur le territoire et pour
ouvrir des optionalités d'accélération
un peu comme la prime à la casse qui a
été mise en place pour les véhicules
thermiques mais je précise une chose
c'est que si on veut effectivement
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
il faut être sérieux et donc il faut
anticiper ces sujets
et et la peur n'excluant pas le danger
nous il nous semble important de poser
ce sujet la manière la plus
je dirais sereine possible en se donnant
le temps mais en étant aussi capable de
tracer des perspectives ambitieuses
d'accompagnement de la filière
d'accompagnement des ménages
je souhaite enfin que nous intensifions
nos efforts sur le nombre de rénovations
performante puisque c'est le terme
consacré au sens de la loi c'est-à-dire
celle qui permettent un gain énergétique
de l'ordre de 50% et surtout pour les
ménages vivants dans les passoires
thermiques une réduction durable de leur
facture d'énergie on en comptait 70 000
l'année dernière elle représente 10% des
rénovations aidés par ma prime rénove en
2021 et 2022 si beaucoup plus qu'avec le
cite mais on sait vous avez donné un
chiffre et la première ministre a
indiqué un premier cap lors du CNR c'est
notre objectif de doubler enfin non même
de quasiment triplés 70 000 à 200 000
rénovations de performance pour l'année
2024 on voit bien qu'on est entraîne
dans le clencher une croissance on a
fait multiplication par 10 des dossiers
de rénovation entre le début du
précédent quinquennat et la fin du
précédent quinquennat là nous sommes en
X 2 entre la première la deuxième année
première année ça dépend comment vous
comptez et la deuxième année évidemment
l'objectif c'est d'accélérer mais là
encore en structurant les solutions et
les filières dernière pour que ça
fonctionne dans cette perspective le
gouvernement entend structurer les aides
en deux piliers des 2024 pour plus de
lisibilité et un meilleur ciblage des
opérations une optimisation de nos
ressources ce pilier performance qui
comprend des aides renforcées avec un
accompagnement obligatoire pour les
rénovations d'ampleur et fait pour les
passoires thermiques et un pilier
efficacité qui va permettre de faire des
travaux en logement occupés autour de
bouquet efficace en couplant de la
rénovation de l'isolation et du
changement de chaudière voir un simple
changement de chaudière dès lors que le
bâtiment est récent et à des qualités
d'isolation qui sont tout à fait
acceptables parce que ça va permettre
d'accélérer il faut aussi avoir en tête
que certains travaux ne peuvent pas se
faire en logement occupé et que
déménager
pour six mois ou demander à des
personnes âgées de bouger on le voit y
compris dans le logement social c'est
pas si simple en tout cas c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire contrairement
nous allons nous appuyer sur plusieurs
leviers structurels pour mettre en
oeuvre ces deux évolutions nous devons
renforcer l'attractivité des opérations
de rénovation près des ménages dans les
accompagnant mieux donc là c'est l'idée
de renforcer le conseil en proximité et
l'accompagnement de bout à bout deux
éléments on dispose aujourd'hui de 550
guichets physiques France rénov notre
objectif serait d'en avoir grosso modo
un par intercommandalité qu'il s'agisse
d'un guichet dédié d'une maison France
service avec une personne formée ou d'un
service dans l'intercommunalité
labellisé France Renov et voit bien
l'enjeu d'avoir ces contrats et ce
travail main dans la main avec les élus
locaux et les collectivités locales la
deuxième jambe c'est un accompagnement
technique qui soit neutre fiable et de
qualité c'est le sens de
dispositif mon accompagnateur rénove il
s'agit de lever le premier finin des
ménages en leur proposant un
interlocuteur de confiance qui a pas
forcément leur dire prenez une pompe à
chaleur ça va être formidable quel que
soit la situation du logement comme on a
pu le voir dans certains
récits
et qui les accompagne dans un projet de
rénovation approfondie parce qu'on sait
que ce sont des projets plus complexes
pour les ménages les plus précaires la
première ministre a acté comme je le
défendais reste à charge zéro sur
l'accompagnement des ménages très
modestes donc là on est juste au niveau
de l'accompagnement et l'objectif c'est
que ce soit un conseil en mode service
public complètement ou vous garantissez
qu'il n'y a pas d'interférence avec des
intérêts pour tel type de technologie ou
tel type de travaux et qui permet aussi
de boucler l'ensemble du dossier dans sa
dimension financière et dans sa
dimension technique ce nouveau programme
qui est financé par les certificats
d'économie d'énergie portée par mon
ministère sera doté à environ 300
millions d'euros c'est les c'est
l'estimation que nous faisons
aujourd'hui pour 2 à 3 ans les niveaux
de prise en charge pour les autres
ménages seront précisés la semaine
prochaine mais je vous confirme qu'il
resteront très important également pour
les ménages du modeste donc troisième et
quatrième des cils
je rappelle à ce titre que nous avons
engagé en mai une concertation avec les
collectivités locales mobilisées sur les
thématiques de rénovation et d'habitat
pour garantir la bonne structuration de
ce service sur le territoire nous aurons
aussi besoin de capitaliser sur l'action
et le volontarisme des collectivités
locales qui sont des partenaires
financiers et 3 de l'État et de la nain
sur cette thématique nous devons en
outre poursuivre notre travail pour
rendre plus incitative les aides et
mieux les adapter à la situation des
ménages en particulier les plus modestes
d'abord en facilitant le cumul des aides
il y a deux aspects structurants le
premier est de faciliter le cumul de ma
prime rénov et des C2E or nous savons
qu'ils ont été conçus de manière
différente avec des logiques différentes
et que du coup c'est pas si simple de
les empiler les uns aux autres du coup
les critères sont différents il nous
semble que ce n'est pas au ménage et en
particulier au plus modeste de faire
toute l'ingénierie financière et le fait
de remplir les dossiers donc ça ça peut
être un rôle important de mon
accompagnateur rénove moi je défends le
couplage des œufs et de rénov au niveau
de l'ANAH le deuxième aspect c'est de
faciliter le financement du reste à
charge grâce aux facilités bancaires et
sur ce point il faut assumer de
retravailler le financement et d'étudier
tous les freins aujourd'hui qui existent
à ce financement qu'il s'agisse de
l'éco-pétée Z ou du prêt avance
rénovation
parce que sinon règle sur le prêt
bancaire vise notamment à prendre en
compte la situation de surendettement ou
d'endettement ou de capacité à
rembourser des personnes les plus
fragiles et que les personnes les plus
fragiles se distinguent précisément par
un revenu fiscal de référence qui ne
leur permet pas de justifier du niveau
de remboursement qui leur est demandé
voyez bien que le serpent se mord la
queue et qu'on a un sujet
d'accompagnement on a des dispositifs de
garanties qui ont été mis en place
garantie d'État et j'entends
complètement l'élément dignité que vous
manifestez sur le reste à charge zéro il
est parfaitement valide puisque pour que
ça marche il faut aussi que les ménages
soient acteurs de la rénovation qu'il
choisisse
le niveau de confort la nature de ce
qu'ils vont et ce qui perdent un petit
peu de mètre carré en faisant
l'isolation d'une manière différente peu
enfin ce projet leur appartient mais de
l'autre côté il faut aussi être
conscient que certains ne dispositifs de
s'activent pas parce que l'ensemble du
dossier de ces ménages ne remplissent
pas les cases pour un classique pré
bancaire ou même un prêt renforcé et
donc je pense que ça il faut l'affronter
peut-être d'ailleurs en se posant la
question d'une rénovation performante de
la baisse de facture de la façon dont on
peut
engager le financement sur la base des
perspectives d'économie d'énergie par
exemple et c'est une façon aussi de
poser la question la rénovation
performante et de la gestion de l'effet
rebond poste rénovation donc j'ai pas de
réponse à ce stade mais je pense que ce
sont des éléments qu'il faut regarder
plus précisément
nous devons ensuite travailler à rendre
les rénovations performantes plus
incitatives que les aides au monogestes
grâce à une évolution des baronnes qui
en gros rendent plus intéressantes le
fait de faire ces trois quatre gestes
très différenciants plutôt que le simple
changement de de la chaudière c'est ce
que je défendrai dans les discussions
interministériales et je pense de
manière assez alignée mais les minutes
qui viendront nous le confirmerons dans
le cadre du projet loi de finances 2024
avec mes collègues de rocklore et vous
avez entendu hier la première ministre a
indiqué que les aides à la rénovation
performante augmenteront l'année
prochaine je souhaite également que nous
regardions les modalités pour aller donc
plus loin avec un reste à charge zéro
sur l'ensemble des travaux je les dis
je pense que il peut avoir un intérêt à
ménager un petit modérateur pour
s'assurer du sérieux des projets mais
j'invite chacun vraiment à regarder sur
des cas précis à quel point ce qui
ressembler être à 10% statistique est en
fait une somme considérable pour les
ménages dont nous parlons je veux dire
sur des travaux de 50000 euros même s'il
reste 10% lorsque vous avez un revenu
fiscal de référence qui est 6000 euros
je suis désolé mais ça pose un problème
on peut le tourner comme on veut mais
c'est une réalité et vous pouvez être un
propriétaire d'une maison Phénix
ancienne qui
sur lequel vous reste peut-être encore
un bout de près où je sais pas quoi qui
est effectivement une passoire thermique
et sur lequel en fait vous n'avez pas de
marge de manœuvre et c'est ces réalités
là qui font quand même adresser de
manière assez directe en tout cas je
renvoie ces sujets aux futurs
discussions budgétaires mais également
la discussion avec les collectivités
locales qui sont nos partenaires
financiers en particulier pour
accompagner les publics fragiles
il faudra évidemment intégrer dans cette
approche les C2E gérés par mon ministère
il représente de l'ordre de 3 milliards
par an en faveur de logement résidentiel
c'est le chiffre 2021 et dès 2024 il
permettront de financer la montée en
puissance des rénovations d'ampleur avec
mon accompagnateur Renov je les
signalais enfin la réalisation de
rénovation
performante pendra pas seulement des
aides et l'ingénierie financière il nous
faut aussi plus de professionnels en
mesure de proposer ces rénovations
d'ampleur et en mesure de créer
rapidement des groupes en d'artisans en
mesure de le faire je crois que c'est un
point assez consensuel dans toutes les
discussions que moi j'ai pu avoir au
Parlement dans les deux chambres la
seconde édition des Assises du bâtiment
à vocation à identifier les freins mais
aussi les leviers activés comme les
recrutements les reconversions dans les
métiers de la rénovation énergétiques
sur ces différents enjeux on le sait la
mobilisation de la CAPEB et de la FFB
sera déterminante et j'espère que les
évolutions que nous apportons en matière
de
lycée professionnel l'enseignement
professionnel reconversion et tout le
travail aussi sur sur France travail
seront des éléments qui pourront
alimenter la mise en place de ces
filières un dernier mot avant de
conclure pour vous faire part du travail
initier avec les ministres Attal
Grégoire et d'ores et d'ores et déjà
barreaux sur la lutte contre la fraude
aux travaux de rénovation énergétique
il est impossible aujourd'hui de
naviguer sur Internet sans tomber sur
des publicités agressives et peu
crédibles sur la rénovation thermique et
chacun en tête des exemples déplaisants
de devis forcés qui voire de vente
forcées de travaux mal réalisés ou de
faux dossiers de fausses primes rénov
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous devons
être intraitables au regard des sommes
que nous voulons mettre en oeuvre en
plus dans cette politique et de la
nécessaire confiance dans le système et
la qualité des travaux menés que nous
devons conserver chez nos concitoyens on
aura donc prochainement l'occasion
détailler ces mesures anti fraude et
anti-arnac elles sont d'autant plus
utiles que si on veut faire de l'allé
vert il faut qu'on permette de bien
distinguer le vrai fonctionnaire qui
appelle un ménage dont on voit qu'il a
toutes les caractéristiques de vivre
dans une passoire thermique et le
démarchage de la société qui est là pour
placer des pompes à chaleur acheter en
Asie et donc je me permets d'insister
sur ce point vous l'aurez compris le
gouvernement poursuit la montée en
puissance de sa politique de rénovation
de logements dans le but de réduire nos
émissions de gaz et effet de serre de
réduire notre consommation énergétique
et d'éradiquer les passoires thermiques
grâce à la mise en place d'un écosystème
performant qui allie pouvoir public
professionnel du bâtiment acteur du
financement et collectivités locales qui
seront absolument clés notamment pour
apporter cette dimension de connaissance
du
tissu artisanal et de l'écosystème local
pour aller plus vite
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
ses propos introductifs donc vous avez
fait souvent référence
au prochain projet de loi de finance sur
lequel certains mesurent bien évidemment
en tout cas être discutées voire voté
par contre vous avez pas parlé de la loi
pluralienne sur l'énergie à venir et
est-ce que ça veut dire que dans cette
loi il y aura aussi des aspects en tout
cas des points qui concerneront cette
politique de rénovation énergétique des
logements
alors oui tout à fait parce que vous
l'avez souhaité je rappelle que la loi
de programmation énergique climat et je
recherche très exactement l'article qui
décrit ce qu'elle doit contenir elle
doit contenir les objectifs de
rénovation énergétique dans le secteur
du bâtiment pour deux périodes
successives de 5 ans en cohérence avec
l'objectif de disposer à l'horizon 2050
d'un parc de bâtiments sobre en énergie
etc et que
via la mise en oeuvre d'un système
stable d'aide budgétaire d'aide fiscale
de l'État ou d'état ou d'aide résultant
du dispositif des définis aux articles
etc accessible à l'ensemble des ménages
et moduler selon leur ressources donc
vous voyez que il faut également tenir
compte des spécificités territoriales
nées notamment en typologie d'habitation
et aux conditions climatiques et les
rénovations portent notamment sur les
gestes de travaux les bouquets de
travaux ainsi que les rénovations
énergétiques performantes et globales
donc tout est déjà en termes de commande
de ce que doit contenir la loi de
programmation énergie climat dans la loi
climat résilience et donc effectivement
nous y travaillons c'est un des objets
du groupe efficacité énergétique du
groupe de travail efficacité énergétique
pour lequel on vous avait sollicité
monsieur le rapporteur
merci Madame madame la Présidente merci
Madame la Ministre déjà pour pour cette
exposition ses explications
bon j'avais beaucoup de questions mais
du coup je pense que mes collègues aussi
complète complètement peut-être revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit au début sur
effectivement dans les politiques de
rénovation thermique enfin énergétique
des bâtiments
c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir deux
stratégies qui devraient en faire qu'une
mais en tout cas un peu en avoir deux et
il peut y avoir cette tentation là sur
l'impact carbone et le rejet CO2 et on
sait que sur les 190 millions de tonnes
de CO2 de 2030 enfin qu'on devrait
atteindre en 2030
l'impact juste sur le logement serait 17
millions de tonnes et donc on pourrait
enfin avoir cette tentation d'aller
justement vers le changement
d'équipement de chauffage et donc
d'aller plutôt sur l'électrique et donc
de décarboner mais vous l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé aussi sur la rénovation
énergétique et thermique des bâtiments
il y a aussi tout l'aspect de santé
confort
baisse du coup et pour le porte-monnaie
de ce qu'il habite et donc voilà comment
vous l'avez un peu expliqué mais comment
justement tombe pas dans cette dans
cette dérive et c'est vrai que si on
regarde les chiffres et un petit peu les
différentes auditions qu'on a fait sur
les petits publics ont été mis en place
jusqu'à présent on peut pas dire que
pour l'instant on soit vraiment sur la
rénovation globale mais qu'on est allé
effectivement en grosse grande majorité
sur du changement de chaudière quoi donc
comment justement réorienter un petit
peu pour faire en sorte que
enfin en tout cas on aille pas dans
cette dans cette dérive en tout cas qui
qui au bout du compte du coup pourrait
pourrait être préjudiciable
et
j'entends aussi sur le fait qu'on se
passe totalement en fait de tous les
moyens de chauffage on va dire
hydrocarbures que ça soit un objectif
il y avait quand même la question sur
les chaudières gaz c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui est ressorti beaucoup
alors qui est compliqué parce que c'est
vrai que c'est peut-être des niches mais
le fait d'interdire en tout cas de se
dire qu'on va se passer totalement du
gaz ça pose la question et vous l'avez
abordé de comment en fait on aborde la
question de manière plus locale et
comment on a plus on travaille plus avec
la spécificité de chaque territoire on a
par exemple un méthanisation avec des
réseaux de gaz qui existent localement
avec des projets de méthanisation qui
sont mis en place et c'est vrai que ça
serait quand même
assez surprenant du coup qu'on ne
propose pas en tout cas sur des
rénovations plutôt là pour le coup des
chaudières gaz plutôt que une pompe une
pompe à chaleur on a la même chose avec
avec les réseaux de les réseaux de
chaleur ou c'est vrai qu'on a pu voir
des préconisations sur la mise en place
de pompe à de oui de pompe à chaleur
alors qu'on avait un réseau de chaleur
et que ce serait beaucoup plus logique
et en tout cas de pouvoir intervenir sur
des jeux de chaleur et et puis
certainement aussi développer ses
réseaux de chaleur ça me permet de poser
la question sur le fond chaleur du coup
est-ce qu'il y a des ambitions en tout
cas pour vraiment développer ce ce fond
ce fond chaleur
et donc voilà enfin en tout cas sur
cette cette prise en compte peut-être
plus locale en fait de des productions à
la fois de production d'énergie et de ça
et de s'adapter au plus près ça me pose
la question de l'implication des
collectivités donc vous en avez parlé
aussi c'est vrai qu'on voit que et dans
les à la fois différentes auditions et
déplacements qu'on a pu faire
[Musique]
important et donc comment vous
l'intégrez dans votre dans votre
dispositif
ensuite une question sur le sur le DPE
par rapport aux différentes auditions
qu'on a pu avoir on a eu bon beaucoup de
retour sur le DPE sur la nouvelle
formule du DPE je pense que globalement
tout le monde se dit que c'est un outil
en tout cas un thermomètre qui est
plutôt intéressant qui permet de savoir
où on en est qu'il faut certainement
améliorer il y a encore certainement des
choses à
améliorer donc une question c'est de
savoir s'il y avait encore des choses
parce qu'on est sur la deuxième phase
mais ce qui avait encore des éléments en
tout cas qui pouvaient se qui pouvaient
être amélioré dans ce DPE parce qu'on a
eu pas mal de retour en tout cas sur
certains sur certains éléments et
déviance qu'il pouvait qui pouvait qui
pouvait y avoir et puis notamment sur
comment et de quelle manière on applique
ce DPE on avait tout à l'heure la table
ronde avec les
copropriétés et c'est vrai que la
question du collectif et une vraie
question et notamment comment on fait en
sorte que dans un bâtiment collectif et
dans une copropriété on se retrouve pas
avec des logements
individuels qui ne serait plus louable
mais sur lequel la personne propriétaire
ne peut rien faire ou en tout cas serait
enfin voilà vous aurez des
problématiques pour faire ces travaux et
donc de raisonner en matière de DPE
collectif serait plutôt quelque chose
qui paraîtrait plutôt intéressant donc
avoir votre votre avis là-dessus et puis
sur les accompagnateurs rénov puisqu'ils
vont faire partie dans le dispositif de
quelque chose de voilà à la fois d'un
nouveau métier mais qui est d'un
dispositif quand même assez important ça
a été annoncé par première ministre du
coup d'un doublement de ses
accompagnateurs rénov dans les
différentes auditions et ce qu'on a on a
encore pas vraiment compris le périmètre
d'intervention des accompagnateurs rénov
et quel sur quel périmètre ils allaient
intervenir est-ce que c'est juste de
l'accompagnement administratif de
recherche une invention d'orientation et
donc voilà et on en reste à ce à ce
périmètre là et on voilà ce qu'on nous a
dit c'est que ça pouvait être des
missions qui vont de 150 à 200 euros
voilà c'est pour ça que je pose la
question
et puis on nous a aussi parlé on va dire
d'un super accompagnateur rénov on va
dire et qui lui ferait la totale de la
mission à la fois l'accompagnement mais
quasi une maîtrise d'oeuvre et donc là
plutôt sur des prestations à 2000 3000
euros enfin voilà ce dont ça donc ce qui
est pas neutre à la fois justement
puisque pour les pour les ménages
modestes ça serait quelque chose qui a
priori ce que vous avez dit serait pris
en charge en tout cas reste à charge
zéro pour le pour l'accompagnateur rénov
donc du coup le financement et le coût
derrière n'est pas le n'est pas le même
et puis surtout dans le dispositif c'est
vrai que suivant le ce qui est
réellement la compagnateur Renov ça
change un petit peu
ce à quoi il sert et comment et comment
on peut fonctionner on peut fonctionner
derrière
et puis j'avais peut-être un dernier
point mais vous l'avez vous l'avez
abordé sur la question de sur la
question de la fraude vous en avez parlé
c'est vrai que je rebondis sur ce que
vous avez dit c'est vrai que si on va si
je fais je me mets dans la place de
quelqu'un qui veut rénover sa maison que
je vais sur un site et que je tape
ma prime rénov 2023 je tombe directement
sur plusieurs sites qui vont me proposer
effectivement des pompes à chaleur et
notamment des sites il y a le site
d'engie essayer de Total etc donc des
sites qui sont pas des des petites
entreprises on va dire et qui vont
orienter directement en fait le parcours
sur sur du changement de chaudière et je
pense que voilà quelqu'un qui va juste
se dire bah tiens comment je peux faire
des économies va se retrouver dans ce
parcours là et en fait va être
totalement en fait exclu justement de
tout cet accompagnement et donc moi je
me posais la question sur le sur la
question du DPE
sur le fait de de généraliser en fait ce
DPE et le puisque pour l'instant en fait
il est obligatoire que sur la vente et
la location et donc d'avoir justement
génération du DPE qui permettrait
d'avoir une meilleure visibilité globale
de l'ensemble des bâtiments et donc de
l'associer au
carnet de santé du bâtiment ou au
passeport du bâtiment mais surtout
d'avoir l'obligation d'avoir un DPE pour
faire une demande de subvention ce qui
permet d'éviter justement d'être orienté
ou mal orienté puisqu'on aurait déjà ce
premier ce premier ciblage et cette
première orientation puisque dans le DPE
il y a aussi des orientations de travaux
ce qui permettrait que les gens sachent
justement quels sont déjà les premiers
travaux à faire et puis ensuite
accompagnateur rénov etc mais voilà du
coup c'était moi sur ce ces orientations
là et puis sur les C2E et puis ma prime
rénove comment vous imaginez parce que
ça c'est aussi quelque chose
qui nous est beaucoup remonté de
d'harmoniser en tout cas on sait que ces
deux dispositifs qui sont différents
mais en tout cas comment faire en sorte
d'harmoniser ces aides et que de la part
de l'utilisateur en tout cas de l'usager
ça soit un peu plus simple d'accès et
puis surtout qu'on n'est pas des
orientations très différentes puis c'est
ce qu'on a pu voir avec les combles à 1
€ ou avec les chaudières 1 € et les
dispositifs qui peut qui peuvent être
mis en place avec ma prime rénov sur de
la rénovation globale par exemple quoi
donc du coup de dispositifs qui vont un
peu dans des sens dans des sens
différents voilà merci
alors
je vais essayer de répondre rapidement
terrible pas toujours
alors comment
réorienter sur enfin qu'elle est sur la
question des chaudières du changement de
chaudière c'est votre première question
est-ce que on a bien intégré donc je le
redis faut pas faire du tout électrique
nulle part c'est pas de notre intérêt
collectif en mix énergétique je sais
qu'on est très électrocentré en France
c'est pas notre intérêt de faire du tout
électrique un fort sur lui quand on a
des réseaux de chaleur disponibles
et des projets qui aujourd'hui vous avez
mentionné le fond chaleur donc je vous
le dis très clairement avec Christophe
bécheux on est très clair aujourd'hui le
fond chaleur et l'outil qui fonctionne
le mieux sur une diversité de projets
puisque ça peut être des projets
collectivités locales au profit des
habitants des projets industriels donc
c'est c'est ou des projets pour les
ménages individuellement je pense
notamment au soutien en géothermie on a
plus de 900 millions d'euros de dossiers
déposés
on était à 320 millions d'euros de
crédit je crois il y a deux ans on est
passé à 570 millions d'euros de crédit
cette année et on voit bien que ça
pousse et c'est pas des mauvais projets
le coût d'abattement de la tonne carbone
de ses projets et très compétitif et
permet de sortir derrière avec
de la chaleur à un niveau compétitif
donc évidemment ce sont des projets qui
doivent être soutenus je dirais c'est
presque des projets sans regret il y a
des sujets sur lequel on peut avoir des
doutes il y a des sujets qui relèvent de
la transition là on est plutôt dans la
catégorie de projets sans regret
s'agissant de la méthanisation et des
réseaux de gaz de choses
la première chose c'est de quoi
parle-t-on est-ce qu'on parle de boucle
courte ou évidemment ça peut être une
incitation à protéger ces situations là
où est-ce qu'on parle d'injection dans
le réseau ce qui est pas tout à fait la
même chose il faut avoir et c'est un des
points qui va être important dans la
planification qui nous attend c'est que
si vous avez mécaniquement au firs et à
mesure
de l'évolution
des habitudes de ce qui sera proposé du
fait que les propriétaires voudront des
fossiliser leurs logements au moment
d'une mutation etc une diminution du
recours au gaz vous allez avoir un coût
du réseau de distribution qui sera
supporté par un nombre toujours
décroissant de personnes
avec un risque que ce soit compliqué on
pourrait le payer ce niveau de coût donc
ça ça doit se faire vraiment en bon
ordre et avec différents scénarios et
c'est pour ça que moi j'invite à être
très vigilant sur l'anticipation le fait
de se poser toutes les bonnes questions
tout de suite ça veut pas dire non plus
qu'on est dans un système 01 je prends
un exemple
la pompe à chaleur hybride qui fait
électrique et gaz ça vous permet dans
des zones froides je regarde dessinateur
corbisé
plus froide
à la fois d'avoir l'électricité les
trois quarts du temps mais quand vous
avez un pic de froid ben vous êtes
capable d'y faire face et donc vous avez
aussi la dimension confort qui qui est
maintenue et le bon dimensionnement du
chauffage donc il n'y a pas de
d'unique façon de le faire de même que
dans les réseaux de chaleur on peut
pousser à une progression
de la part de renouvelables dans le
réseau de chaleur mais c'est pas 0,1
c'est à dire du jour au lendemain on
change on change de logique c'est il
faut regarder d'ailleurs sur ces sujets
là ce qui s'est passé au Pays-Bas alors
qui sont beaucoup plus gasi que nous
mais au Pays-Bas et en Allemagne
puisqu'ils ont fait ces concertations et
ils ont même été amenés à revoir
certains paramètres qu'ils avaient
retenus parce que je trouve que c'est
riche d'enseignement et notamment sur
cette dimension progressive mais de
signaux qu'on donne pour permettre à aux
filières de se structurer et notamment
nous ce qui est très important pour nous
c'est les filières industrielles on a
beaucoup d'acteurs qui sont très bons
sur la chaudière gaz mais qui ont déjà
une offre pompe à chaleur là aussi je
pense évidemment Atlantique et d'autres
producteurs français le marché européen
va totalement décoller il faut juste
faire en sorte que le basculement vers
ce nouveau marché soit soit fait dans
les temps c'est à dire qu'on brusque pas
qu'on n'attendent pas trop longtemps non
plus pour que nos industriels puissent
suivre et avoir et pouvoir adapter leur
appareil de production aujourd'hui ils
sont ils sont prêts en tout cas on a des
produits de grande qualité plutôt de
meilleure qualité que ce qu'on peut voir
en dehors de l'Europe
sur la question des collectivités
locales je suis complètement en ligne
avec vous quand j'ai mentionné les
maisons France service
ça n'utilise pas le sujet c'est à dire
ça peut être un point français service
qui a une capacité à parler de France
Renov ou ça peut être un le guichet de
la collectivité locale dont on dit
puisque vous avez déjà l'expérience
puisque vous avez déjà les les ménages
qui viennent vous voir on vous labellise
France rénov et à telle ou telle
condition contractuelle donc
l'enjeu c'est de d'avoir
un point d'entrée France rénov qui soit
grosso modo présent sur toutes les
intercommunalités en utilisant les
voiles les plus évidentes dans le
dispositif d'aller vers physiques que
nous avons donc soit le guichet de
l'interco soit un guichet qui existe
déjà mais qui n'était pas spécialisé sur
la rénovation soit un guichet spécialisé
déjà sur la rénovation
sur les effectivement il faut pas casser
ce qui existe déjà c'est plutôt
un risque de retarder les politiques que
nous portons
sur sur le diagnostic et sur le
collectif je pense que mon collègue
Olivier Klein et mon collègue Christophe
BECHU qui ont les budgets m'imprime
rénov sérénité en propre
vous répondront plus directement sur ces
sujets
mais effectivement on a un plan d'action
pour
améliorer la qualité des DPE donc
renforcer les compétences des
diagnostiqueurs sensibilisation
formation un meilleur outillage des
organismes de certification des
diagnostiqueurs et plus de contrôle
terrain et puis sur les décisions
collectives également réfléchir aux
modalités de prise de décision en
copropriété des choses qui ont été déjà
traitées sur les décisions sur la
batterie enfin les bornes de recharge on
sait qu'il y a des travaux sur ces
sujets là
sur mon accompagnateur Renov il a bien
une mission approfondie donc c'est
plutôt plusieurs milliers d'euros que
moins d'une centaine d'euros ou
plusieurs centaines d'euros trois
objectifs un accompagnement technique
audit énergétique recommandations de
scénario de travaux orientation vers des
artisans RGE et aide à l'analyse des
devis et c'est à eux de justement de de
proposer des bouquets les plus efficaces
au regard de ce qui
est visible enfin des informations sur
le logement un accompagnement financier
aide à la mobilisation des aides
financières disponibles pour réduire le
reste à charge possibilité
d'accompagnement administratif dans la
réalisation des démarches et c'est là où
à mon avis il y a un travail à faire
justement pour une des autres questions
l'alignement c'est de eux ma prime
rénove j'ai l'habitude de dire à mes
équipes qu'à un moment les Français ils
veulent des prestations c'est la cuisine
interne et de savoir quel dispositif en
empile de quel programme de quel numéro
de programme ça dépend et qui les gère
ça devrait être totalement transparent
du point de vue de minage là encore
c'est beaucoup plus facile à dire qu'à
faire mais je pense que c'est vers ça
qui faut tendre j'ajoute une chose c'est
que je pense mais c'est un avis
personnel c'est une proposition que j'ai
fait mais il faut qu'on l'approfondisse
qu'on dispose d'énormément de données
sur
de donner opérationnelle informée enfin
sur les logements on connaît leur grâce
à inédits on connaît leur consommation
on connaît grâce à
côté gaz avec Gaspard leur consommation
on connaît leur nombre de mètres carrés
par
exemple les fichiers fiscaux donc on
devrait être capable par la mise bout à
bout de données de dire vous êtes vous
consommez 30% de plus qu'un logement
équivalent en termes au mètre carré
et comme votre ménage n'a pas l'air
d'être d'avoir des usages anormaux on
pense que vous devriez vraiment vous
saisir parce que vous avez un gain
énorme à faire sur votre facture enfin
donc on a assez data là on a l'idée les
données sur les la rénovation et on
commence à avoir des retours
d'expérience sur toutes les rénovations
qui nous permet de dire qu'est-ce qui
est le plus efficace ou moins efficace
et on peut rapprocher la consommation
post rénovation de ce qui a été fait
comme bouquet donc tout ce champ là de
Data devrait être investigué plus avant
pour à la fois permettre de sécuriser
des parcours plus efficaces par rapport
à l'objectif et de l'autre côté faire du
aller vers les bonnes personnes
et je pense qu'au niveau d'une d'un
territoire et avec des collectivités
locales qui sont motivées pour le faire
on peut vraiment pointer les politiques
et donc c'est le troisième volet de mon
accompagnateur rénov c'est
l'accompagnement social dans les
situations de précarité énergétique
d'habitat en ligne ou de perte
d'autonomie parce que le vieillissement
de la population va mettre une couche
supplémentaire dans la nature des
travaux qui va falloir faire on pourra
avoir des travaux à la faveur des
travaux vous en profiter pour faire des
travaux d'accessibilité de facilitation
de la vie pour une personne âgée
donc mon accompagnateur rénov peut
d'ailleurs réaliser des missions
supplémentaires par rapport à ces
fondamentaux que j'expose
DPE obligatoire
c'est la difficulté qu'on a c'est qui
d'ailleurs explique que
les dans les statistiques que l'on
suivait sur le supplément de 1000 euros
dont on qui était versé pour ceux qui
faisaient le diagnostic avant après et
qui montrait un changement de catégorie
en fait on a eu 2500 dossiers parce que
le coût du DPE faisait qu'à la fin vous
dites bon pour 1000 euros de plus je
vais pas faire un DPE plus puisque c'est
quand même assez coûteux donc faut pas
sous-estimer c'est pour ça qu'on est
souvent en frein dans les discussions
qu'on a au Parlement lorsqu'on veut tout
conditionner au DPE en disant attention
c'est aussi un frein au passage à l'acte
parce que il y a cette marche à franchir
du coup et je reviens à mon antienne
précédente si vous rapprochez les
données de consommation du nombre de
mètres carrés
et a priori
sauf à sortir des points un peu
extraordinaires parce que vous avez
précisément un faïencier qui travaille à
la maison et qui consomme beaucoup
d'énergie mais sur 90% des ménages vous
êtes capable de pointer des situations
d'écart à la moyenne de la consommation
attendue par mètre carré donc on
pourrait
sortir des éléments alors vous le dites
il y a les premières pistes de travaux
il y a la manifestation des ponts
thermiques etc mais
si on met la haie au trop haute le
risque c'est que il y a un refus
d'obstacle donc ça c'est là où pareil on
ne cherche à positionner les politiques
publiques au bon niveau
je vous en prie
ces conditionné aux aides d'ailleurs
une la prime en tout cas il faut avoir
le
un DPE
[Musique]
ça permet quand même de franchir
l'obstacle en fait je me suis
mais ça fait une étape de plus
du coup je suppose qu'il y a d'autres
questions
inscrit pour vous poser des questions on
commence par Jean-Pierre corbiset oui
merci
chers collègues trois petites questions
pour la première avec beaucoup d'humour
je vous pose pas l'action savoir si vous
êtes satisfaite que c'est grâce à Sony
qui est cité énergétique que le Racing
Club de Lens et le vrai vainqueur de la
Liga
mais je suppose que vous l'êtes comme
tout comme moi bon plus sérieusement
madame la ministre vous avez parlé de
d'amplification de massification de
rénovation énergétique et surtout
performante et quels acteurs vous pensez
mobiliser vous les avez cités à les
collectivités le filaire du BTP
l'éducation nationale mais à un moment
donné il faudra bien voir un chef
d'orchestre à tout ça parce que déjà
certains de nos collègues sont déjà
intervenus dans l'hémicycle sur les
problématiques du dossier informatique
de la prime rénov ou pour certains ça a
été parfois le parcours du combattant à
remplir ça n'est jamais facile est-ce
qu'à un moment donné il y aurait pas un
seul pilote à mettre en place dans tout
ça de façon à être vraiment efficace la
deuxième question enfin la dernière
comme l'a dit monsieur le rapporteur
c'est la problématique de l'arrêt du gaz
fossile et du démarrage du gaz d'hiver
parce que les Pays-Bas eux ont reculé la
date butoir de l'utilisation du gaz
fossile tout simplement parce que on se
rend compte que tout simplement pour des
raisons financière
quand le gaz vert va arriver ceux qui
sont déjà propriétaires d'une chaudière
gaz n'aura rien à faire dans leur
charnière gaz pour changer de système de
gaz or comme on dit tout à l'heure les
médias Facebook pour pas le citer et
d'autres
on a tous les jours une publicité la
région des Hauts-de-France finance pour
1 euro votre pompe à chaleur vos
panneaux photovoltés etc et aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens avec des revenus
modestes se font effectivement des
marchés en disant carrément il faut
arrêter votre chaudière gaz et passer à
d'autres systèmes plus performants comme
le pellet la pack ou le photovoltaïque
or on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
comme je l'ai dit le jour où le gaz vert
va arriver GrDF a largement dépassé 100
pourcentage prévu de production de gaz
vert est-ce qu'à mon on est on peut pas
décaler dans le temps la fin du gaz
fossile et accélérer la production du
gaz vert si je dis ça c'est comme vous
l'avez dit Madame la mise dans mon
territoire dans notre territoire
respectif on a un grand groupe un des
derniers groupe français Atlantique qui
fabrique vient de sortir un modèle
innovant de chaudière gaz pack et c'est
le meilleur système avec une sonde
extérieure parce que quand vous avez par
exemple une plaque une chaudière appelée
vous pouvez pas basculer à l'instant T
d'un type de chaudière à l'autre c'est
pas possible techniquement c'est pas
possible c'est trop dangereux alors qu'à
l'inverse ça a qu'une chaudière gaz pack
le start and Go ou le Schwitz se fait
tout seul et je pense que pour des gens
il est revenu modestes ce genre de de de
projet que met en place le groupe
atlantique
a déjà des débouchés au Pays-Bas mais
pour l'instant la mauvaise réputation
faite aux chaudière gaz actuelle fait
que les groupes industriels sont très
inquiets sur leur avenir de fabrication
de ce type de matériel comment
pourriez-vous effectivement intervenir
pour éviter ce genre de publicité
mensongère qui commence à fleurir dans
nos boîtes aux lettres
vous laisser répondre
alors je vous confirme que ça réchauffe
les victoires telles que les inconnues
ces dernières semaines je sais pas si ça
suffira à répondre à l'enjeu de
transition énergétique du territoire
mais ça montre que lectif ça marche si
on doit se dire quelque chose et que il
faut pas forcément un gros budget pour
atteindre des résultats comme ça vos
figuiera la métaphore
sur la question de la
des acteurs
je pense que et c'est un petit peu le la
philosophie dans lequel nous travaillons
on a Lana qui est clairement aujourd'hui
le pivot de notre politique de
rénovation thermique mais qui va aussi
accompagner les enjeux d'accessibilité
vieillissement de la population et
d'habiter à indigne
c'est un pivot naturel qui a vos
vocation à effectivement accompagner les
personnes ayant dit cela nous nous
faisons le pari avec Christophe Béchu
que il y a une voix pour contractualiser
avec des intercommunalités qui sont
prêtes je dis qu'ils sont prêts parce
que vous mentionnez tous les c'est pas
il faut les moyens il faut la structure
il faut les personnes formées enfin il
s'agit pas d'appuyer sur un bouton et
pour effectivement se dire à un moment
dans le cadre d'un cahier des charges
compressif comment on peut justement
passer
déléguer en fait c'est
[Musique]
ces crédits de rénovation et faire en
sorte que le relais soit pris et que
justement il y a cette connaissance du
terrain et y compris d'ailleurs souvent
des ménages dont on parle pour permettre
ces accompagnements avec
un degré de confiance qui est renforcé
parce que c'est plus facile d'aller
chercher l'artisan du coin qui fait bien
les travaux parce que c'est plus facile
de écoute peut-être pas cette année
Mélanie prochaine où on travaille bien
le dossier enfin c'est autant d'éléments
qui sont pas négligeables sur les
territoires et qui peuvent permettre des
passages à l'acte et il y a un bon et un
bon travail et ensuite il faut
effectivement mettre toutes les
ressources disponibles en matière
d'information de datage je le disais et
je pense qu'on ne va pas suffisamment
loin aujourd'hui pour vraiment très
rapidement
spécifier une situation et et et donner
déjà les trois quatre conseils qui font
80% de
de la prise de conscience de ce qui est
possible pour un ménage et de ce à quoi
il a droit et de
ce combien de temps vont prendre les
travaux enfin des questions qui sont
très qui sont très légitimes on touche à
l'intime quand même c'est les
habitations des gens souvent dans lequel
ils sont depuis des années donc
là aussi la nature de l'accompagnement
est quand même essentielle
sur la question du du gaz vert
j'attire
l'attention sur les enjeux de de quoi
parle-t-on on parle de 480 tirawatths de
gaz fossiles
480 watts c'est autant grosso modo vous
avez si on est très caricatural vous
faites 500 de carburants 500 gaz 500
d'électricité dans notre mix énergétique
très caricaturale donc c'est autant que
toute l'électricité qu'on consomme la
capacité aujourd'hui à injecter du
biogaz dans le réseau c'est 10 Terra
water
2%
. le la biomasse disponible pour demain
répondre à tous les usages sur lequel
les demandes sans piles biocarburant
bio
biogaz
[Musique]
alimentation de d'un certain nombre de
réseaux etc
on constate et c'est un travail que nous
menons avec Marc fenou pour dire combien
de biomasse le système agricole et en
capacité de sortir de manière
raisonnable combien on est capable
éventuellement d'importer et comment on
transforme ça et à quel usage on le
destine sachant que la biomasse agricole
par construction elle a trois priorités
nous nourrir nourrir les animaux
d'élevage
et préserver le pic carbone
ça veut dire que quand même on est dans
une équation qui n'est pas si simple
donc en fait je pense qu'il faut
vraiment très vite se retirer l'idée
qu'il suffit d'attendre que le gaz vert
arrive pour enlever la et remettre la
prise ça sera pas si simple après dans
des endroits déterminés il y aura
effectivement la faculté de le faire et
en fait à chaque fois on aura une
question de mérite order d'ordre de
mérite des utilisations
un des biomasse 2 du biométhane et
d'alternative notre objectif étant de
dire mais j'enfonce une porte ouverte je
destine ma biomasse par ordre de mérite
d'abord effectivement je
sécurise des besoins absolument en
premier donc je commence par
l'alimentation et deuxièmement je prends
je sécurise les besoins sur lequel je
n'ai pas d'alternative en décarbonation
donc on sait par exemple que la chaleur
haute température aujourd'hui on n'a pas
tant alternative que ça et dans
l'industrie et que le bioga c'est pas
complètement idiot en revanche est-ce
que
dans une maison de ville où je l'ai
alternative d'un réseau de chaleur basé
sur ses serres où j'ai l'alternative
d'une pompe à d'une pompe à chaleur
classique où je peux faire de la
géothermie parce que je suis sur enfin
parce que c'est pas comme à Nice je suis
sur un gisement et bien c'est peut-être
ça qu'il faut privilégier et on va
vraiment être dans ces logiques là d'où
la nécessité d'où notre objectif et
notre ambition au travers de la
planification énergétique qu'on a
projeté dans la loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables d'amener tous les
territoires à se poser ces questions là
de c'est quoi mon c'est quoi dans le
sens mes énergies les plus accessibles
compte tenues de ma géographie c'est
quoi mes problèmes les plus criants
parce que entre ceux qui ont trop de
chaleur et ceux qui ont trop qui ont
continueront à avoir du froid ça sera
pas la même histoire ce courant un accès
des petits méthaniseurs et ceux qui
seront dans de l'habitat danse et qui
donc seront sur des installations plus
industrielles enfin en fait
la réponse est multifactorielle
et ensuite nous on est garant des grands
équilibres nationaux c'est-à-dire de
dire en gros on fera jamais 500
terawattheure de biogaz ça c'est faux il
faut pas mentir en revanche ça serait
pas mal d'arriver à en faire autour de
50 terawatters 40 50 c'est déjà 10 15%
du sujet
et ça on a la filière on a la filière
elle a le bon goût d'être quasiment
intégralement française donc pas
tellement de filière énergétiques à part
le nucléaire contre beaucoup d'être
quasi intégralement françaises on a les
compétences et il faut maintenant
enlever les obstacles sur le chemin
c'est ce que je fais en signant par
exemple des textes sur les arrêtés
tarifaires biogaz etc mais c'est un peu
la démarche qu'on a c'est à dire qu'on
aura nécessairement des solutions
multifactorielles
typiquement dans votre territoire il y a
le gaz nominain le gaz de mine pareil ça
sera une micro-réponse à certains
territoires du Pas-de-Calais n'empêche
que aujourd'hui avion qui en profite
sont ravis mais mais il y aura peut-être
10 communes qui en bénéficiera ça sera
jamais une réponse
pour tout le monde sur la publicité que
vous mentionnez moi je pense que c'est
un problème qui est absolument majeur
surtout quand on est ministre et qu'on
se retrouve en dessous en photo du truc
à 2 euros à 1 €, qui est gratuit bon
enfin des fois c'est la première
ministre carrément puisque pourquoi pas
avec la Marianne qui est utilisée
Jean-Noël barreau dans son projet de loi
sur la fraude et les sites internet à
d'autres manières génériques de tous les
outils maintenant il faut les utiliser
de même qu'il faut utiliser signal conso
de la DGCCRF et il faut probablement
réfléchir à la manière de d'être plus je
dirais drastique sur toute forme sur
toute forme de démarchage
moi j'avais porté la loi sur le
démarchage téléphonique qui interdisait
le démarchage sur la rénovation
thermique vous avez pu constater que ça
avait été extraordinairement efficace
puisque nous continuons à tous démarcher
et en plus sur notre 06 donc voilà il y
a un enjeu effectivement de de lutte et
nous constatons mais comme dans beaucoup
de sujets où vous avez de l'argent
public y compris des schémas de fraude
qui sont internationaux et porter par
qui relève du Grand burditisme
qui s'adapte à la forme du terrain et
qui développe des schémas de capture de
du numéro fiscal etc pour monter des
faux dossiers donc
Gabriel Attal a entamé un grand cycle
fraude social fraude fiscale fraude à
toutes les aides publiques et on s'est
dit que c'était un objet qui n'était pas
petit qui méritait d'être traité alors
merci madame la ministre il nous reste
un petit quart d'heure on a encore
quatre questions de nos collègues donc
on va grouper Michel Dagobert et Pierre
met de vieille et ensuite on terminera
avec Amel gaker et daphnéagmadou
allez dépêchez-vous
merci madame la Présidente de ce
rapporteur merci madame la ministre pour
votre propos éliminaire qui était déjà
très complet et
un certain nombre de réponses aux
questions des collègues nous permettent
d'avancer sur
les questions je vais aller à
l'essentiel donc conserver juste une
question qui concerne ce que vous avez
évoqué sur le allez vers notamment pour
les gens qui sont en précarité
énergétique ils sont aussi bien souvent
en précarité tout court et parfois rien
que de franchir le pas de de passer au
guichet ou d'aller à la rencontre des
accompagnateurs ça peut représenter une
difficulté donc il y a déjà cet aspect
là et puis on a évoqué aussi le le
concours que pourrait apporter un
certain nombre de collectivités on a
déjà vu des collectivités régionales ou
départementales s'engager et pour autant
elles ont elles-mêmes un patrimoine
assez conséquent parfois je pense pour
le conseiller départemental que je suis
une ancien président que j'étais les
départements ont bien sûr les collèges
mais ils ont aussi des partenaires dans
la sphère médico-sociale je pense
notamment un département comme le mien
compte 115 foyers logements qui datent
des années 70-75
ou nous intervenons auprès
d'associations qui
accueille des enfants confiés à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et qui les héberge
dans ce que notamment dans le bassin
minier ces grandes maisons de maître qui
ont des plafonds très hauts qui sont
très mal isolés et donc le département
risque aussi d'être sollicité par ces
associations lorsqu'elles vont devoir
améliorer à la fois le confort des
enfants qu'elles accueillent mais aussi
leurs factures en matière énergétique
merci pierre-médocl
merci madame le Président merci madame
le ministre nous sommes des
remerciements groupés aussi dans
logiciel d'être rapide madame Lamy sur
ce qu'on a beaucoup parlé du résidentiel
pensez-vous qu'il y a des solutions
peut-être spécifiques pour les bâtiments
du tertiaire ne souffre-t-on pas de
problème de réactivité c'est vrai qu'on
voit dans d'autres pays des solutions
simples qui me semblent pour être mise
en pratique en France je pense un
exemple qu'on a vu dans un salon à
Tel-Aviv c'est un bâtiment qui est
parfaitement dans le tertiaire et qui
est fait alternativement de panneaux
plein d'eau de panneaux plein d'huile
c'est simple comme la joie mais ça
marche avec des panneaux photovoltaïques
dessus et l'été sa glace l'eau et
l'univers se chauffe l'huile et ça
marche c'est autonome ça
on vous laisse répondre dans le ministre
et après on terminera avec un méga care
et d'acheter un cadeau
alors
je l'ai dit sur les bâtiments et je vais
faire le lien entre tertiaire et
Messieurs messieurs vous pouvez écouter
madame la ministre qui vous répond je
sais pas excusez-moi
merci madame la Présidente
sur les bâtiments publics il s'agit des
bâtiments états des bâtiments des
collectivités locales
ou des bâtiments du tertiaire je le
redis il faut qu'on ait un vrai travail
de fond sur les trajectoire et un
travail qui partent d'abord de la
sobriété c'est-à-dire quel bâtiment on
conserve quel mètre carré on conserve le
premier la première façon compacter nos
émissions de CO2 dans le bâtiment c'est
moins de mètres carrés et sur les
bâtiments du tertiaire c'est pas
complètement indifférent parce qu'il y a
un gisement en la matière et sur les
bâtiments
vous mentionnez à monsieur le sénateur
des foyers logements qui sont
manifestement dans des bâtiments qui ont
pas tout à fait été conçus pour être des
foyers logements initialement à un
moment effectivement il y a la question
de comment on projette et est-ce que
c'est les meilleurs bâtiments est-ce
qu'il faut pas
trouver d'autres d'autres lieux pour
accueillir ce type
ce type de
de de personnes mais ce qui suppose
quand même des sacrés bougés parce
qu'évidemment moi je vois très bien quoi
vous faites référence pour avoir
quelques ponts thermiques dans
cette voilà ça pas été conçu pour ça
c'est très clair
et donc il faut des budgets derrière
avec le ministre Béchu nous poussons
pour une pour qu'il y ait une
augmentation du fond vert et au sein de
cette de cette de ce fond vert une
allocation pour la décarbonation des
bâtiments publics et il faut qu'on ait
une trajectoire sur les bâtiments
publics état de la même manière de toute
façon je vais être très clair
les directives européennes sur le sujet
des bâtiments publics
fixe des objectifs très élevés et plus
élevé que dans le privé et auquel on a
un peu du mal à échapper
donc ça sera dimensionnant donc il vaut
mieux s'en préoccuper en 2023
qu'attendre 2028 pour se réveiller avec
un sentiment d'inachevé
sur la question du aller vers
je pense qu'effectivement il y a un
travail alors est-ce que c'est au niveau
du département qui a un certain nombre
de fichiers de précarité la précarité
énergétique n'est pas nécessairement la
précarité tout court c'est à dire que
vous pouvez être un ménage aux revenus
moyens c'est-à-dire à 1600 1700 euros
par mois
et qui enfin Monsieur Madame
mais qui est dans une passoire thermique
et qui du coup paye une facture
énergétique totalement décalée par
rapport au nombre de mètres carrés
qu'ils occupent et du coup qui se
retrouvent dans une situation de fin de
mois un peu difficile ce que ne
laisserait pas présager leur situation
de de salariat stable à des postes par
exemple dans la fonction publique etc
donc
ces situations là effectivement faut
aller au devant et c'est là où
j'interroge moi la question de
d'utiliser les données de consommation
d'énergie puisque nous avons je vous le
dis il faut qu'on en soit fier nous
avons le réseau de distribution
électrique le plus digitalisé au monde
qui est classé en première position par
5 par les spécialistes les experts de
Singapour pas dire qu'on a influencé
leur
classement et donc on a une qualité de
données qui n'a pas d'égale dans le
monde
logement par logement
donc il faut l'utiliser et ça c'est
vraiment dommage qu'on soit pas allé
encore jusqu'au bout donc ça je pense
que c'est un élément qui qui n'est pas
négligeable de même effectivement que
d'utiliser
toutes les tous les moyens par je pense
qu'on pourrait demander aux
énergéticiens de faire des alertes en
disant il nous semble que votre facture
est un peu élevée par rapport à ce qu'on
comprend notre logement
on vous adresse on vous remet le numéro
vert de France service ou le machin ou
éventuellement un moment on propose un
rendez-vous téléphonique enfin on peut
aller sur des systèmes comme ça en
disant vous propose un rendez-vous
téléphonique de telle heure à telle
heure le sujet étant de séparer le bon
grain de livré c'est à dire plus on fera
d'aller vers plus on donnera pièces à
des gens qui font du aller vers mais
agressif pour aller placer des pompes à
chaleur ou autre chose et faire des
travaux de mauvaise qualité donc c'est
là où on a
difficulté c'est pour ça que je pense
que le rôle des collectivités locales
pour sécuriser le trajet et et le
meilleur parce que pour le coup en règle
générale vous connaissez sauf dans les
très grandes villes vous connaissez à
peu près votre mère vous connaissez les
services et donc vous avez vous êtes
plus sûr de à qui vous parlez et des
personnes dans lequel vous remettez le
destin de votre logement
sur le bâtiment du tertiaire là vous
avez mentionné une technique que je ne
connaissais pas donc vous me
l'expliquerai en aparté
manifestement le sénateur dagdberg ne la
connaissait pas non plus
et plus sérieusement
deux choses nous on fait le départ entre
les plus de 1000 mètres carrés les moins
de 1000 m² sur les plus de 1000 mètres
carrés
on considère qu'on est face à des
acteurs raisonnablement structurés qui
se sont déjà emparés du des critères
ciel et on suit avec une plateforme là
aussi qui
récupère toutes les données de
consommation qui méritent d'être
fiabilisée c'est la première année où on
l'a à disposition d'une année sur
l'autre et qui va nous permettre de
suivre la réalité des données de
consommation et de derrière faire des
rapprochements et des sollicitations il
nous semble que ça vaudrait le coup
aussi de regarder le système de sanction
telle qu'elle est prévue par la loi
climat résilience parce que dans la loi
climat résilience vous avez une
sanction administrative de mémoire qui
doit être de 7000 euros par bâtiment
mais en fait c'est pas considérable
si vous êtes un grand groupe avec du
logistique ou magasin par exemple au
hasard
c'est pas une incitation à passer à
l'action si on vous fait payer la
réalité de vos émissions de CO2 en
supplément par rapport à
ce que vous auriez dû faire au prix du
CO2 au moment où ça se pose je pense que
ça sera une sorte de prise de conscience
un peu plus forte et ça permet aussi de
d'éviter les passagers clandestins là
encore ce n'est pas du tout des choses
tranchées c'est
j'alimente des idées qui ne sont pas
d'ailleurs qui sont pour poste de 2030
donc on a encore le temps de
spécifier la stratégie mais ça fait
partie des éléments sur lesquels il faut
qu'on soit clair il faut ensuite
accompagner les plus petits moins de
1000 mètres carrés moins de 500 mètres
carrés dans l'ordre de progressif et là
on va avoir un sujet de mobiliser sur
des diagnostics énergétiques ou sur des
plus globales comme le fait on le fait
aujourd'hui les CCI PMA à la fois dans
les pratiques opérationnelles je suis
cordonnier je suis boulanger je suis
commerçants donc quelle est ma
consommation d'énergie et quels sont mes
obligations regarde du décor des
décrétaires et comment je me mets
progressivement
en
règle avec ce décret de quels je peux
bénéficier vous savez qu'Olivia Grégoire
et Christophe bechus entraînent
avec mon support de montée un portail de
tout ce qu'il faut savoir en gros sur la
transition écologique à destination des
PME recensant les aides et les
obligations voilà le type d'outils que
l'on met en place mais c'est clair qu'il
va avoir un avion un accompagnement avec
une granularité qui est pas tout à fait
la même chose pour les aller 5000
entreprises qui sont structurées
aujourd'hui pour faire face et les deux
millions d'entreprises pour qui ça va
être encore quelque chose à faire dans
leur
dans leur vie d'entreprise et pour
lequel on doit effectivement accompagner
anticiper expliquer faire la pédagogie
dire ce qu'il y a de positif qu'est-ce
qu'il y a à gagner dans tout ça parce
que qu'il y a à gagner c'est des
moindres factures c'est des aides qui
sont mises à disposition c'est le
sentiment de contribuer à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique c'est
quelque chose à valoriser vis-à-vis de
ses clients là encore plus facile à dire
qu'à faire
merci Madame la Ministre leur très
rapidement amaliaquer et devenir
rakmadou
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre on ne peut pas parler je pense
du défi majeur de rénovation énergétique
sans parler forcément des besoins
massifs de compétences dans les métiers
notamment du bâtiment vous en avez parlé
très brièvement tout à l'heure je sais
que vous l'avez vous avez en tête cet
enjeu là mais comme dans d'autres
secteurs l'activité de la rénovation
énergétique fait face à une
problématique de taille celle de la main
d'oeuvre disponible et qualifiée et en
particulier de personnes nouvellement
diplômées sur les métiers de rénovation
thermique qui demande des connaissances
des compétences spécifiques Lana
estimait à 100 à 150 000 recrutements
nécessaires pour renforcer la ce marché
en tout cas où renforcer le travail à
faire sur la rénovation d'ici 2024 et ce
dont tout type de métier une grande
partie des besoins vivent notamment les
métiers de l'artisanat maçons couvreur
menuisier des professions recherchées à
qui on demande de nouvelles compétences
l'usage de nouveaux matériaux de
nouvelles techniques des compétences
aussi en termes de connaissances de
réglementation donc ça c'est un point je
pense essentiel qu'il faut aborder et
puis un autre enjeu mais qui est lié à
cette problématique là c'est la très de
ces métiers auprès ou en tout cas de nos
jeunes vers ces métiers est-ce que
aujourd'hui on peut dire que les
formations initiales sont suffisantes
est-ce qu'elles intègrent justement
également les enseignements aujourd'hui
adapter à ces enjeux souvent les
professionnels que nous rencontrons sur
le terrain nous disent qu'elles doivent
former ces jeunes sur le terrain donc la
question se pose également et puis donc
suite à ce constat-là ma question est de
savoir aujourd'hui face à cette ambition
importante en matière de rénovation
énergétique est-ce que il y a un
véritable eff Ort massif aussi en
matière de formation et de recrutement
prévu merci Daphné
la Présidente
je voudrais d'abord élargir quoi revenir
à l'élargissement par rapport aux
attentes d'objectif de 2050 on voit que
l'effort va être assez considérable et
la clé pèse passe par une baisse et une
transformation de la consommation mais
aussi et donc de la sobriété
la sobriété qui actuellement avec la
hausse du coût d'énergie a été d'une
manière contrainte un certain nombre de
personnes et même de collectivités et
qu'il faut arriver à pérenniser il faut
arriver à pérenniser ses baisses on voit
qu'après une rénovation globale c'est
pas forcément systématique c'est qu'on
consomme pas moins en fait on perd ses
habitudes éventuellement de sobriété
donc il y a vraiment un enjeu là-dessus
après sur un zoom plus sur le terrain
moi j'ai un light motif par rapport à la
préoccupation de la précarité d'été qui
est trop peu prise en compte et
sous-évalué actuellement dans les
réflexions y compris
jusque dans le formulaire et dans la
l'accompagnement ma prime rénove et
c'est un enjeu parce que si on se
retrouve avec des rafraîchissements
électriques on aura tout voilà et qu'on
ne prend pas en compte
dès le début avec des solutions qui
parfois sont assez faciles pour
accompagner et diminuer ce
cette précarité d'été je pense que c'est
extrêmement important et l'autre pendant
c'est la clé en fait et essentielle du
conseil de service public d'objectivité
monsieur le rapporteur en a parlé tout à
l'heure par rapport aux Alecs nous c'est
vrai qu'on est seul on en a un certain
nombre mais ça marche extrêmement bien
il y en a que 40 enfants donc c'est pas
sur l'intégralité du territoire mais ça
permet de restaurer la confiance et
d'avoir vraiment un tiers de confiance
pour pouvoir être accompagné et c'est
une des clés pour pouvoir passer et être
sûr d'avoir choisi les bonnes solutions
pour la rénovation globale
voilà les dernières questions madame la
ministre
alors sur le volet compétences je vais
d'abord dire une chose c'est que au fond
on est en train de mettre le doigt sur
un élément qui est essentiel c'est que
la transition énergétique va produire
des besoins de compétences sur des
métiers qui sont bien rémunérés et qui
constituent autant d'opportunités pour
nos territoires
[Musique]
dont on aura besoin sur tout le
territoire donc là aussi il y a pas de
concentration des métiers il y a
vraiment une très bonne répartition sur
tout le territoire c'est des
opportunités extraordinairesment
importantes pour notre territoire au
moment où certains voudraient nous dire
la transition énergétique se fait contre
les classes populaires au détriment des
plus pauvres je pense que c'est
important de le valoriser aussi c'est un
avenir qu'on construit pour nos jeunes
le deuxième chose c'est concrètement
comment on s'y prend il paraît être très
bonne question
je l'ai indiqué
il faut
mobiliser les acteurs de l'emploi pour
de la formation initiale en passant par
le la continuité la reconversion les
régions un rôle important vous êtes bien
passé pour pour le savoir
on a besoin de mobiliser la filière si
tout l'enjeu des deuxième assis du
bâtiment où nous allons nous avons
demandé à la CAPEB et FFVB de travailler
sur des propositions sur la manière
effectivement de construire ces filières
notamment sur la formation initiale et
continue des pros pour une meilleure
qualité des travaux on a un sujet de
malfaçon aujourd'hui donc il faut
traiter à la fois le flux les jeunes qui
arrivent mais il faut traiter le stock
qui n'ont pas été formés à ces nouvelles
technologies qui n'ont pas été formées à
ces enjeux
c'est pas mal de
s'assurer de que voilà ils ont eu accès
à ces formations
et puis il y a une animation locale des
filières et un renforcement de leurs
connaissances de la connaissance des
aides auxquelles ils ont accès
au-delà de ça moi je peux vous faire un
témoignage dans les j'étais dans le
lycée professionnel de Béthune
Salvador aliendé dans ce lycée
professionnel les sections qui
attirent dans le proviseur et Séverine
Gosselin vous connaissez bien qui attire
enfin les sections qui font le plein
aujourd'hui ce sont des sections qui
sont autour de la de la transition
énergétique du génie énergétique etc
pause de panneaux
de panneaux photovoltaïques système
électrique
et c'est un élément de d'attraction des
jeunes donc effectivement il faut
reconstruire le récit et c'est ce que
nous voulons faire avec
des la cinquième
des présentations des métiers des
perspectives et plutôt dans un format où
il n'y a pas d'enjeu c'est à dire que en
5e vous n'êtes pas encore à vous
projeter sur votre métier et vous
regardez pas vos notes de maths et de
français pour savoir si c'est plutôt ça
ou plutôt ça
dans suite arriver en troisième avec le
fait d'avoir expérimenté et c'est comme
ça notamment que le lycée fonctionne une
journée ou une semaine pour voir comment
ça se passe en vrai est-ce que ça vous
convient est-ce que c'est plutôt la
section X ou la section y qui vous
convient de faire sauter cet obstacle et
moi je le vois très bien sur ce
territoire il y a beaucoup de gens du
Pas-de-Calais vous aurez remarqué dans
cette pièce
de cet obstacle qui est celui que moi
j'ai entendu de jeunes de troisième qui
me disent ah non mais j'irai pas en
mécanique parce que c'est à 10 km de la
maison et donc je vais faire BTP qui est
à 5 km de la maison et là vous vous
dites c'est pas possible parce que le
gamin il peut y aller même en vélo
il y a en plus c'est pas si mal des
services ça quand même donc il y a cette
chose là à faire sauter et effectivement
derrière de mettre en valeur ces métiers
penser à une plateforme et à
valorisation de tous les métiers dans
parcoursup dans qui participent à la à
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique nous avons un projet
collectif qui est de rendre notre
planète plus vivable vous en êtes parti
prenante et de l'autre côté un autre
extrême de la chaîne il y a tout l'enjeu
de l'emploi des seniors dont il me
semble qu'ils ont un rôle aussi assez
essentiel à faire en termes
d'accompagnement de transmission alors
peut-être ils sont pas formés à la
rénovation thermique mais ils sont
formés
à faire fonctionner à travailler ils
sont formés sur les bonnes attitudes ils
sont formés sur et donc cette
transmission peut se faire et on peut
même penser à du cumul emploi retraite
donc il faut jouer sur les deux bornes
il faut jouer sur les reconversions et
il faut effectivement mettre en place
les filières ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement il faut
aussi avoir
les structures de formation ce que
j'observe c'est qu'on commence à avoir
un peu à un switch moi je le vois sur le
nucléaire notamment ou en tout cas sur
les formations un peu bac+ quelque chose
bac + 4 + 5 on commence à voir plus de
candidats que de place en termes
d'attractivité c'est entraînes de bouger
mais il faut l'accompagner mais vous ne
pouvez pas demander à un jeune qui n'a
aucun modèle dans sa famille de ce type
de métier de ne pas avoir des préjugés
sur les métiers en question
et donc ça se travaille dès la sixième
et la 5ème ça se travaille avec les
parents d'élèves et ça se travaille
aussi avec le corps enseignant qui n'a
pas nécessairement été exposé à ce
métier cette proviseur me disait combien
il était important aussi de faire venir
les enseignants et les proviseurs et le
corps enseignant de des établissements
caractères généraux général pour leur
montrer concrètement comment ça se
passait et pourquoi en fait c'était des
jolies perspectives pour les pour les
jeunes en question et que c'était des
vrais orientations rien de pire qu'une
orientation par défaut parce que
géographiquement c'est plus proche de la
maison ou parce que vous avez été
mauvais en maths pendant toute l'année
alors que c'est pas le sujet si
certainement pas le sujet de choisir
entre
électricité
plomberie ou mécanicien
très bien merci beaucoup madame la
ministre pour cette audition qui était
très complète voilà on va
la sénatrice reikman 12 qui est pas très
correcte donc je vais le faire très très
vite
vous avez raison de pointer le fait
qu'il faut coupler efficacité et
sobriété
moi j'aimerais qu'on arrive à mettre en
place c'est pas encore évident des
contrats de performance qui permettent
aussi de valoriser la réalité la
diminution de la consommation d'énergie
à la fois comme modèle de financement
mais également comme engagement pour
finaliser par exemple le paiement de du
soutien
ce qui permet aussi de former les
ménages à l'utilisation de l'équipement
qui n'a l'air de rien mais en fait
c'est possible
sur la précarité d'été nous allons dans
le cadre de la campagne enfin de du plan
2 sobriété faire effectivement un volet
sur
les bons gestes l'été à la fois dans le
bâtiment également quand même par
rapport au carburant parce que faut
qu'on aille nettement plus loin sur la
sobriété pour le carburant mais sur le
bâtiment c'est notamment la question de
la climatisation que la loi
traitée puisque nous sommes pas censés
démarrer la climatisation à moins de 26
degrés tu veux pas dire que il faut
attendre qu'il fasse 26 degrés pour la
mettre à 20 degrés je dis parce que
et derrière ça si en fait mettre en
place tous les systèmes de
sobriété pour barrer les rayons du
soleil enfin il y a plein d'éléments qui
existent de trucs mais derrière ça il y
a aussi la question de l'adaptation
changement climatique c'est-à-dire que
typiquement sur les écoles le plan
comporte de rénovation des écoles il a
aussi un volet été pour éviter que les
gamins soient 35 degrés et que ce soit
insoutenable et que ça gêne le travail
sur sur le conseil de service public
c'est toute la logique
oui c'est pour ça voilà
je pense qu'il y a un petit problème de
gestion de techniques du bâtiment je
vais me permettre il y a tout un sujet
de si tout le sujet de mon
accompagnateur rénov c'est d'avoir ce
conseil qui soit neutre et qui ne soit
pas orienté qui du coup puisse instaurer
une relation de confiance avec le
ménage les ménages donc je partage votre
point de vue sur le fait que cette ce
service public là doit être renforcée
c'est ce que nous faisons
merci merci savez-vous que le Sénat est
chauffé par la géothermie mais oui
puisque nous sommes en train
d'expérimenter
cette option à rocklore et que vous
savez que l'Élysée démarre ses travaux
ce que j'ai vu mais le Sénat c'est déjà
fait mais néanmoins